pleased to have back here after his
second draft as a head coach in the
national football league
carolina's matt rule how are you coach
i'm doing great thanks for having me on
thank you for coming on greatly
appreciate it
what was it like in your draft room the
number of times i'm sitting there on the
set and i'm hearing the panthers are
trading down i lost track
because and then you moved up you mean
you were all over the board what was it
like that night
in that i think they were there there
were a lot of nervous coaches and scouts
right there and they watched other
people draft them but you know uh
we uh you know i think the other day it
worked out it was um
it was uh it was nerve-wracking at the
time to be quite honest you know because
you're taking some gambles but
um you know at the end of the day though
the risk you know the risk wasn't
outweighed by the reward
so let's uh let's jump right into it if
you don't mind uh you had the choice
of every defensive player on the board i
mean that's incredible
that's that had never happened in the
history of the draft that that uh
somebody eighth overall could be sitting
there having every defensive player at
their at their ready because the draft
had never started with seven offensive
players
in a row um were you close to making it
eight offensive players
you know you know we had we had thought
about it i mean we liked a lot of the
guys that you know obviously the guys
went before us and
and uh the the guys that were there um
but you know we we looked at jc horn as
as like being the perfect uh the perfect
player for us
a great player you know son of an nfl
player so he's grown up in it
love the way that he plays and then
obviously fills a need for us
and so um i think any time you can get a
guy that you feel really
good about not just what they do on tape
but also
you know who they are and their and
their mental makeup you know
um it was it was a pretty easy pick for
us well i mean uh you you had like i
said
every defensive player available to you
and there was patrick certain
as well i know you just kind of
mentioned that you liked the fact that
his dad played in the league and he
maybe grew up around the sport what why
why else jc horn over patrick certain
from alabama
you know i don't think anything uh uh
negative to either player i just think
you know as we as we as we spent time
with jc on zoom you know i went to the
pro days i just kind of watched him
walk around and interact with people you
you can just
feel his competitiveness and so you know
that that's
that's something that i that that that i
love and um
uh there were lots of other guys that we
knew like hey these guys would help us
they'd come in and play
for us but but jc um there was just a
certain edge a certain vibe to the way
that he plays that
that just kind of jumped off the tape
and i think it wasn't just me i mean i
think our
our secondary coach our coordinator our
gm i thought i think everyone felt that
and and you know he is the way that we
want to play
and uh was it any point of view because
again i'm sure you're very happy to get
him and excited to get him
any point at all you're like am i ever
going to choose an offensive player in
the draft because
i mean your entire first draft was
defensive players coaching
crazy yeah uh you know i looked over at
the offensive staff
and you know you could you could see
them and then i think mr tupper our
owner you know he was you know
he's he was kind of saying are we ever
going to do someone on offense in a kind
of a joking way but
um you know again we we we love the kid
and then i got back in the second round
and we were able to get a wide receiver
and then you know a couple offensive
players after that
so um but yeah there were there were
definitely some guys on offense that
were like why do we even write these
reports if you're not gonna
nice i mean wide out tackle tight end
from notre dame and tommy tremble and
then
chuba hubbard who had a terrific career
at oklahoma state all
all four offensive players after all of
that but uh in terms of uh
an offensive player coach i think i'm
not telling any tales out of school that
the uh nfl media writ large the number
of people that i spoke to prior to the
draft
that was saying carolina absolutely
would take a quarterback
if the quarterback was available despite
having acquired sam darnold who i'll get
to with you in a second
you had justin fields and also mac jones
on the board
uh were were they not ranked high enough
walk me through why
you didn't actually go in that direction
no no i love those guys and i think that
they're going to be great nfl players
um you know i just think uh for us um
when we got sam and uh just
you know again you know no one you know
he's 23 years old just turned 24. we
just felt like
um sam plus another player you know
would be better for the team overall you
know bill parcells once said you know
one you know one player can't do it
alone and so we're just trying to build
the whole team and
and i just believe in sam i believe that
you know he deserves the opportunity to
go out and
and play with us and i think i think
those other young quarterbacks are going
to be fantastic players but
but you know the the hit rate on first
round quarterbacks isn't real real
high and to have a chance to get jc horn
and half sam darnold we just kind of
felt like hey this is two for one
um now we just have to make sure sam's a
great player for us well i mean coach
matt rule carolina panthers here on the
rich eisen show uh
i think i've said this to you before and
if not you may already know it or
as a jet fan um who was you know
at the time also hoping maybe you would
get hired there
um a couple of years ago hearing the
words deserve the opportunity and
associated with sam darnold like
uh you know huzzah for that like yes
he deserves it he deserves the
opportunity and the conversation about
him
not being properly evaluated because of
the circumstances surrounding him in new
york for the first three years
i lost track of the number of times i
hear that how did you evaluate him how
are you able to evaluate him
by saying let's go get him uh as an
organization how are you able to do that
yeah
this all happened kind of in you know in
a weird way you know um
you know we we were sitting there one
day on defense and we were
i can't remember we were watching we
were watching a cut up and
you know sam was playing on the other
side of the ball and a couple times he
made some throws
and uh phil snow our defensive
coordinator was like man that kid looks
like matt stafford and so
we put a we put a couple of games on
this is the defensive staff
and they were all like you know what
every game we watch that he makes a
couple of big time plays and
um there has to be some meat on the bone
there and so i kind of went through the
process and kept watching him and
and going back and watching him in
college and watching his pro day and
then
going back and watching his first year
in a different offense in the second
year in his third year and
um you know when the compensation was
enough where you know we didn't have to
give up
what we thought was too much you know
that would hurt our team and a chance to
get him here
we had watched so much tape on him that
we saw enough shining moments
and then you know what's been really
good for us is after getting him here
um you know talking to god talking to
robbie anderson who played with him
talking to other guys who played with
him
there's not many guys who've been his
teammates who say anything bad about him
like they all have believed in him and
believe that he can be good and
hearing you know some of his former
coaches talk about him they believe that
he can be good and so
i've always been kind of a a a a
nurturer versus nature guy you know i
think
uh people have to be in the right
situations and you know hopefully a
change of scenery is what he needs
and hopefully um you know he comes here
and plays with robbie again and dj moore
and christian mccaffrey and
can just go out there and be one of the
guys and and play well and he's insanely
positive too
matt i mean the number of times that i
would run into him at you know at events
or
at the super bowl after the jets had a
disappointing season and he would say we
could we've got this we're going to get
this right i kind of would look at him
because then
you've spent time in new york you know
so you just say
really and you kind of look at him in
the face and say does he really believe
it and he does like he's an insanely
positive person on top of it how much
from your
experience while you were maybe kicking
the tires and the jets and vice versa a
couple years ago when you went back to
baylor
did you utilize any of that
conversations that sam i imagine you
were connected with him in that process
that you were able to lean on that as
you acquired him this time around
yeah when when the when the jets the
folks uh
first class folks when they came to the
waco to enter you know interview me one
of the first things they did was pull
out an ipad and had me you know uh
uh facetime or skype or whatever it was
with sam
and this is after his first year and he
you know had a pretty good first year
and we're talking and the thing that
always hit me was you know he didn't
want to know who the offensive
coordinator was he didn't want to know
what kind of offense we were going to
run he didn't care who the quarterback
coach was
you know he was asking me about the
culture of the team about the way things
would be run
he was interested in like you know in
discipline and accountability
and to me when your best players when
you're starting quarterback when you
know
you know when your tailback when you're
starting linebacker when when your best
players
uh are are yearning and believing
discipline accountability process all
those different things
you have a chance and that always stayed
with me and
you know that one didn't work out but
you know coming into this i knew without
having a chance to talk to him
i knew that he believes in the same
things that i believe in you know that
it's not just talent you know it's
talent that
is all pulling in the same direction and
so uh that that interaction with him
made me feel better when we made the
trade
matt rule carolina panthers head coach
here on the
rich eisen show how's mccaffrey doing i
mean i i do see him on instagram every
now and then live in
la vida loca uh but is he is he
is he back to 100 ready to roll a whole
bit for this season
yeah i think christian's uh you know
he's at 100 and i think he's
he's going to have a fantastic year you
know um you know i see him sometimes
walking in and out of the building
um he's you know he's he's
i think last year was just you know the
total of a couple of seasons in college
and in the pros you know he's done a lot
i think
you know it's all just kind of caught up
with him for a bit and i expect him to
come out this year and
and hit the ground running and i know
he's excited i know he's mentally
in that in a really good place and
physically in a really good place as
well
well i know it and it's kind of a very
touchy subject certainly with him
because that was the conversation coming
out of college is that he was a fine
piece of stanford china
you know that uh that that few people
saw play because he was dominating at
12 eastern time at midnight and that he
wouldn't be able to run between the
tackles and man did he carry
a large load are you planning on still
having that large load placed upon him
in 2021 yeah i think i think you know
um we want we want to do that within
reason you know we want to give him
every chance to affect the game
but at the same time you know we also we
also want to make sure that
that we keep him healthy for you know
for 17 games and
you know we want to be a team that goes
to the playoffs so we also want to you
know have him hitting his stride late in
the year so
you know drafting chuba was a big part
of that you know making sure that you
know we had
a guy that you know we could spell him
with some of the other guys that we have
here already
so we'll use him but we'll just try to
make sure that we're really smart
about uh about the toll that he takes
and then about the future here
coach i mean you got as you point out a
23 year old quarterback we all know
brady is
sometime gonna have to retire right
uh matt ryan uh the falcons just decided
to
uh draft in a manner that sticks with
him as he's approaching 40 and we all
know that the saints
have just lost their goat quarterback do
you feel like you're positioned to be
the team of the future in this division
that rule um you know that's hard to say
i mean
but we we we've taken an approach you
know um you know when i got here there
was a lot of guys that were kind of you
know ready to move on and so
you know over the course of two years
we've really turned a lot of the roster
over
and i think you know our average age on
this team is like 24 years
24.2 you know we're the youngest team in
the nfl and so
um there's a nice cohort of guys you
know mccaffrey and dj moore
and sam darnold and and and guys on
defense jeremy chin
they're all kind of they're all kind of
growing up in this program together so
we want to be a team that you know with
these draft picks we just drafted that
can be really good for a while and the
other teams in nfc south are outstanding
teams
um we just uh we're just a young team
that's you know hopefully really hungry
and
and and ready to make some noise you
know i know it's i always
sometimes coach uh when i ask i'm asked
like what's it like to work for
the commissioner roger goodell what's
like to work for your boss it's you know
you you
you always wonder if the answer is you
know straightforward people wonder you
know like
am i really telling the truth who's
going to tell the truth about their boss
so on and so forth but what is it like
coaching for a hedge fund
manager what's that like oh i i mean
it's it's unbelievable i i you know
i i love working for dave david depper
like
um the the the questions he asks
um you know like like he he leaves the
football to me and scott you know
um but he he asks unbelievable questions
because he sees the world in such a
special way
and so um like what you got a good
example of a guy
what do you got for me i can't even
think of something off the top of my
head i'm sorry
that's okay um i just think he's always
you know he's always he's always saying
why or have you thought of this and
anything from like you know just just
the way that we travel to everything i
mean he's got such a unique eye and a
unique way of seeing things
and to me that's so valuable like i
think when you put a staff together like
if everyone thinks the same then
then really no one's thinking and so um
to have someone on the outside that
that that is constantly asking questions
and good questions and coming up with
ideas
um i think it's i think it's i think
it's really
important and at the same time this is
he's a he's a tremendous person i mean
this is a guy that like
this is a guy that like you know talks
to my son you know before the baylor
game and you don't want to you know i
mean
this is a guy that knows my kids names
this is a guy that you know calls
players on the team when things happen
this is a guy that
you know my assistant just had a baby
yesterday and you know mr tevers one of
the first
people to reach out to him i mean he he
cares a lot about the people in the
organization so i i'm really blessed and
certainly have a great owner i love what
you just said
uh because it kind of sums up a lot here
when when
everybody's thinking the same no one's
really thinking what did you mean by
that i think i know what you mean by
that
but um yeah what does that mean
well i just think that you know um you
could have a lot of group think
especially in the nfl where everyone's
kind of afraid every year hey am i going
to lose my job
what do i got to do to keep my job hey
just keep you know keep things simple
like
you know uh bill parcells you know you
used to believe you know you
would talk about how conflict is needed
and you know really at the end of the
day like
i want to i want to be a part of a staff
where we're not afraid to go in a room
and argue
and sometimes loudly with different
ideas and different opinions and we
never say to ourselves well that's the
way we've always done it you know
we're always trying to do something
better and new and unique
i think when you have that a everyone
feels like they have a voice
but b you have a chance to be innovative
you have a chance to be on the cutting
edge because you're not just doing what
everyone else does and so
um we want people who speak their mind
and i think what's really
cool about the carolina panthers is uh
there's no you know we don't
compartmentalize that
you know i expect scott federer to walk
into me and say hey why are we playing
so and so there
um and just like i want him to hear my
opinion about personnel and
and you know we don't want to say hey
everyone just stick to your area we want
to be a place where we talk and
communicate and
and argue and at the end of the day when
we make a decision then we're we're
rocking with it
so if you don't mind conflict it's okay
if jc horn brings a cell phone
on the field we're good with that then
i got to tell you now this is this is
true uh when i went to the pro day
yeah i was pulling up the park and i saw
joe horn work
walking in the parking lot and i kind of
turned into like
17 16 year old matt rule like i like
stopped the car in the middle of the
parking lot and got out and just said
mr horn my name is matt rulin the head
coach of the panthers it's really just
kind of such an honor to meet you and
and uh because like he's someone i i
looked up to and respected and as a
player and
um now he's just a dad which is awesome
but uh i i
definitely fanned out for a minute yeah
plus there's no flip phones anymore too
right it's all smart phones now hey
before i let you go did you reach out to
scott drew
um you know what it's like building a
championship team in baylor or
attempting to win a national
championship
in baylor um and i'm sure you must have
had a lot of interaction with him
on the campus after they won yeah i mean
i love scott drew i uh
i um i you know obviously i texted him
after the win but you know i always i
thought
that the week the game before the final
game you know they were shooting really
poorly and
um from three and he made a halftime
adjustment man and they
they started taking the ball to the rim
in the second half and found a way to
win and go to the championship game and
i texted him after that game i said i
don't know anything about basketball
coach but that's one of the best coach
games i've ever seen and
he he uh when i was at baylor he was
crucial to our success
he because he would always reach out he
knew people in town he would always be
positive you know
we went through a lot of really hard
stuff at mayor early on and
you know um it was it took a tremendous
toll i think on all of us on the staff
as people and
he was someone that always had our back
and always was positive with us as was
kim mulkey
um you know another national
championship coach so i was really happy
for scott and i'm excited for coach
mulkey now as she heads to lsu
yeah yeah no doubt and i mean if anybody
knows about tough beginnings at baylor
it certainly would be scott drew
yeah i mean my gosh and taking over so
um
he he came on the show and boarded that
team that that team just spanked
everybody
in the tournament and i just figured i'd
i'd ask you what you thought about it so
that's a good dude thanks for the call
coach really appreciate it always enjoy
our chats look forward to doing it maybe
during the summer before the season
we'll chat thank you all right thank you
guys you got it that's matt rule
everybody carolina panthers head coach
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here